nabil karoui chef du parti crampton ses
anciens candidats à la présidentielle
tunisienne de 2019 a été placé samedi
avec elle son frère le député ghazi
karoui sans détention provisoire par la
justice algérienne pour entrée illégale
sur le territoire alors qu'un compromis
semblait être trouvé entre aller à tunis
pour une extradition de l'homme
politique tunisien la justice algérienne
a décidé de son maintien en détention
provisoire j'ai fait clôture définitive
du dossier est les précisions de notre
correspondant à tunis pas service
cela fait près d'une semaine que les
frères karoui sont entre les mains de la
justice algérienne pour entrée illégale
sur le territoire nabil karoui chef du
parti attrape-tout nous deuxième
formation politique du pays et son frère
le député ghazi karoui ont été placé
samedi en détention provisoire par le
parquet de constantine en algérie chez
l'homme d'affaires et ex candidat à la
présidentielle tunisienne de 2019
avaient fui la tunisie peu de temps
après la décision du président kaïs ayed
de geler le parlement et d'interdire la
sortie du territoire à toute personne
poursuivie pour corruption après la
clôture des investigations préliminaires
menées par la police de tébessa le pôle
pénal spécialisé de constantine a décidé
de maintenir les deux hommes sur le
territoire algérien malgré la demande
d'extradition de la tunisie c'est le
tribunal de premier instance de
catherine au centre ouest de la tunisie
avait lancé fin août un avis de
recherche à l'encontre des frères karoui
suite à l'arrestation d'un
narcotrafiquant soupçonné d'avoir
facilité la fuite de nabil et ghazi
karoui est le chef de file du parti et
cal tounes on a pas fini avec la justice
le 15 juin dernier il avait été libéré
après six mois de détention pour des
accusations de blanchiment d'argent et
d'évasion fiscale après que la cour de
cassation de tunis et rejeté la décision
du pôle judiciaire de prolonger sa
détention faute de preuves maintenu à la
prison d'el kedia constante il l'habille
cas où il risque jusqu'à six mois de
prison pour entrée illégale sur le
territoire algérien avant le possible
extradition vers la tunisie